hey guys
how's it going today i'll be teaching
you
the ancient art of architectural
handwriting
architectural handwriting was developed
during a time
when architects used to draft everything
by hand
this was a very tough time for
architects
if you made one single error you could
be punished
with death of course
we don't have rules like that anymore
we also do most things on the computer
but you'll be amazed at how many times
we have to annotate drawings by hand
good handwriting can complement
your drawings and bad handwriting
can sometimes ruin a good drawing even
if you're not an architect
a unique beautifully handwritten note
can impress so many people architectural
handwriting is both
beautiful and functional
they're very organized and strict
but has a very warm and animated
touch to it they're made up of uniform
block letters
and are very easy to read
and it has very clear proportions
and straight vertical lines like
any other skill it takes time
and deliberate practice but
it can be very rewarding once you master
it
so in this video i'm going to show you
how you can practice it
with some downloadable worksheets that
i've created for you
first you'll need to go and
print your worksheet if you don't have a
printer handy
you can just try to follow my
instructions here
as clearly as possible
you'll need some trace paper and some
pens
[Music]